монумент людей ще біжить перед
готелем build він будинків ілюстрації жартах
примов сюди черв'яний пакет і нехай допоможуть
грійте 18 го дон ліжка корейський
міністрі
би скочувалась представлені до ми
міжнародного валютного фонду євро
центробанку чи то єврокомісії ми на вигляд
ходом і виду - ти
ми продовжимо про пряме з організаціями та
доволи успішним звуча я але і про ітан і
деталей кіно мч типу 3 багато говорить та
про те я співав ми можемо зруйнувати але ти
вчений у будинок тут підпишемо догоду якимось
атаки у них новий план приватизації
механізм врегулювання проблемних
кредитів то жорсткий бюджет не параметри
їхнього вузла дав і до десятих до сотих за
раді без дефіциту науку штори су вже
наступна уроку і ряд скоро ти з
чиновником зарплати
топити ви шукаєте подарунки за цяо фен out
римович кредит 86 мільярдів євро
простіше по три впровадьте прийдемо на
виплату бурге у кредитором за нову
букву створюєте достатню суму на 1
година протікала нам вона і її буде не
достатньо для повного винними
грецької економіки
краще за все налити після праски буду на
лапки для дадуть кого допомогу вже 20
серпня
і типу ви на виплати там оиші три з
половиною мільярда євро
європейському центробанку тапах асети 2
прострочених перед МВФ платежі tanna у
класно у воду поспішати на вище афіни
червоне їх не кредитори тисяч не пхати
організацій кейс поспіхом протирати з
влада вибрати її прогрес тут ноги та
хлопчик лама подалі в прогрес
учасника пари можуть жувати ще до річки
нас і особливо не деталі угоду можете
класти в церкві з подіваюся ще до 20
серпня
важливі віші запас пік я кисть реформ про
прилюдно позицію берліну мова так
німецького уряду штеффен зайберт у
четвер ризики парламентарі може
розгорнутий новий документ або шакал його
але і вихваляти міністру фінансів
єврогрупи йому вірна у 5 ти впали
достатньо рішення якіра ніші без п 3 мг
опозиційних фракцій різкому
іду на убійтесь поважайте експерти я кину
батоги
традиційного масового не ставила не
огром один урізанням доходить